let's instead go to is it Lincoln from
Boston or Boston from Lincoln it really
could be either
Lincoln from Boston Lincoln from Boston
welcome to the program
it's great to be here I wanted to ask
you about the 2024 election Lincoln are
you originally from Boston
I was born in Massachusetts about like
25 minutes south of Boston but yes
interesting because I detected a very
slight like almost like a Canadian
accent there
uh no Canadian here okay I mean it
wouldn't be an insult by the way Canada
is a beautiful place but all right go on
Lincoln
well so uh it is my understanding that
in 2020
when Joe Biden and the Democratic party
won the presidential election okay um a
lot of that was due to events
transpiring that year namely covet of
course and the George Floyd protests
and I'm worried
in 2024
unfortunately it's awful to say this but
if there isn't major events like that
that take place I'm worried the
Democratic party won't have
um that fuel to to win
so I don't know that I necessarily agree
with the premise as far as the George
Floyd protest I don't know how big of a
factor the George Floyd protests were in
Biden's when I do think Trump's
mishandling of kovid was a hundred
percent a factor in Joe Biden's win but
I generally agree with your conclusion
which is you're worried about Biden's
ability to win in 24 and here's my view
on that
it's much
how can I say this you're at an
advantage in terms of how you can
campaign if you're not currently in
power and so even though we know that
Trump accomplished nothing of value
while he was President we know that
Trump made all sorts of promises that he
could never possibly keep we know all
these things right but the fact that Joe
Biden has been in power and if Trump is
the nominee he will have been out of
power or if Ron DeSantis is the nominee
he will never have been president they
can attack Biden in a particular way
that you can't when you're the person in
charge I think it's a benefit to whoever
is the eventual Republican nominee and I
have significant concerns about whether
Biden would win that election I don't
know that any Democrat would necessarily
win
uh in that situation when Democrats have
been in power but I do think that it's
going to be an uphill battle
I appreciate that answer um
just something I'm worried about and uh
yeah I mean I guess my premise um I
wasn't totally certain whether the
George Floyd protests and the covid-19
pandemic both contributed to Biden's win
that was just kind of my understanding
of what happened that year yeah but uh
thank you very much all right my
pleasure there is a Lincoln from Boston
with an extraordinary
um assessment I would say to some degree